For 11 years.
He hosted one of the most popular art shows on television,
transforming a blank canvas to a finished painting in a remarkably short,
30 minutes.
He captivated audiences with is mesmerizing voice and is relaxed demeanor.
And of course his signature palm nearly 25 years after his death.
The painter of happy little trees is immortalized through Internet memes,
inspirational quotes,
say thriving business in his name and reruns of the show,
the joy of painting his famous a pop culture icon shows no sign of diminishing.
Yes,
so little is known about his life today on biographics,
we pieced together the world of Bob Ross beyond the canvas.
Wilbur Ross was fiercely privates and never reveal details of his personal life.
He gave very few interviews claiming no one bothered to ask him.
Looking for answers is especially difficult considering that no official
biography of his life exists from primary sources,
the ones documentary,
Bob Ross,
the happy there can only be obtained by pledging money to PBS or getting a hold
of a DVD.
Copy the book happy clowns,
happy trees.
The Bob Ross phenomenon admitted that their text is about an understanding.
We have of Bob Ross and his life.
If we had wanted to write an accurate biographical book on Bob Ross,
that goal would be difficult to to accomplish adding to the elusive Ross.
He was said to have very few friends and they out of respect,
I only ever conducted interviews for the Afa mentioned documentary that is not
readily or widely available.
Facts are hard to come by and nearly impossible to verify.
Still some specifics are known and so far remain undisputed.
So here's what we know.
Robert Bob Norman Ross was born on October the 29th of 1942 in Daytona Beach,
Florida to Jack a builder and competency alia waitress when Ross was just a year
and a half folds his parents divorced and Ross moved to Orlando.
Not much is known of Ross's childhoods in Orlando.
Save for two defining moments as a freshman in high school,
Ross wanted to drop out in order to work as a carpenter alongside his father.
Around this same time,
Ross suffered an accident losing the tip of his left index finger on a saw
blade.
Ross must've been self conscious about his deformed hands for the rest of his
life on his hit television show.
The joy of painting Ross carefully disguised it,
holding his pains,
pallets so that it remains shielded from view.
Most of the time,
Ross was known to be an animal lover his entire life as a youngster.
This may have been passed on from his mother as a teenager.
Ross allegedly kept exotic paths including armadillos and alligators later on in
his life.
His pet gray squirrel sometimes made an appearance on his television show.
Ros One said,
if we're going to have animals around,
we all have to be concerned about them and take care of them.
Bob Ross married twice during his life and had three sons.
He married his first wife,
Linda Brown,
early on in his military career and they divorced in 1981 the couple had two
sons,
Bob junior and Steven.
Steven would follow in his father's footsteps and became a certified Bob Ross
painting instructor Ross,
his second wife,
Jane,
was a civilian in Alaska.
They had one son,
Morgan,
who would also become an accomplished artist.
Sadly,
Jane died from cancer in 1993 and Ross did not remarry
long before his time on public television.
Ross was in the military at the age of 18 Ross joins the United States air force
and within a few years he was uprooted from his native Florida and sent to an
entirely unfamiliar place.
Fab Banks,
Alaska Ross spent the next 20 years of his life in Alaska working,
raising a family and developing a love of painting amidst the majestic
mountains,
towering pines and crystal clear waters examining Ross's paintings over his
lifetime.
One can see without question,
the trees,
peaks,
valleys,
and streams are distinctly Alaskan.
Eventually,
Russ rose through the air force ranks do master sergeants after holding
positions as a medical records technician and first sergeants of the clinic at
Nielsen Force space,
these positions required him to be in his own words,
tough and mean.
He was the guy who makes you scrub the latrine,
the going who makes you make your bed.
The guy who screams at you for the English to work,
Ross gains a reputation for being hardened.
His subordinates who nicknamed him bust them up.
Bobby.
For anyone who has watched Ross on the dry of painting the image of him as this
authoritarian military figure.
It couldn't be further from his television personality.
Apparently Ross yelled so much during his military career he never wanted to
raise his voice again and after he left the Afro
right crosses
first brush with painting or curves as an asset class of the Anchorage Uso club,
but he clashed with his abstracts of loving instructors.
According to Ross,
they failed to teach him the practical techniques of how to paint the telling
you what makes the tree,
but they wouldn't tell you how to paint a tree.
Fortunately,
the experienced and turn him away from painting altogether.
Ross soon found a more suitable painting instructor on public television.
Ross,
his predecessor,
was an older German pains and names Bell Alexander.
He hosts today at half hour instructional painting show that magic of oil
painting on a PBS.
Watching the show,
Ross learns how to paint in the other prima style.
This is Italian for fast attempts,
also known in the art world as wet on wet.
Ross perfected the technique which allows him to complete a finished work and
these single session.
Unlike other painting methods,
when an artist uses our premed,
he or she can add wet pains in layers without waiting for the paints to fully
dry.
Alexander got falsely claims to have invented the starboard.
It actually dates back to the 15th century in Flanders,
which is Modern Day Belgium.
I looked pretty much was popular with many famous artists throughout history,
but enjoyed great fanfare among the impressionist painters in the 19th century.
Notably,
it was a favorite technique of artists,
Claude Monet and John Singer Sargent [inaudible].
After further honing his skills,
Ross decided to supplement his air force pay by selling landscapes painted on
the inside of gold prospecting pans to tourists.
It was a lucrative and ans when his earnings from painting,
so pastors military salary,
he resigned to become a full time artist.
Upon leaving the air force roster tend to Florida and sought out bill Alexander
in order to perfect his painting skills.
By that time,
Alexander taught art classes in his spare time and happily took on the IGA.
Ross Alexander didn't realize that Ross would later take everything he got from
these lessons,
make his own show and rise to the level of superstardom he did.
This actually eventually led to the two men falling out during the early
meetings.
Alexander was impressed with Ross.
Cindy hired him as a traveling tutor for the Alexander Magic art supplies
company.
At the same time,
900 miles away from Alexander's Studio in Clearwater,
Florida.
A woman named Anne Ness.
Kowalski was experiencing a debilitating depression after losing her oldest son
and a traffic accidents unable to get up.
She,
they didn't bed all day watching television episodes of the magic of oil
painting desperate and hoping to chair his wife up.
What was it going while ski signed an Asop for a five day pains in class with
Alexander or so she thought before and that's arrival.
Alexandra had passed on his classes to an unknown instructor known simply as
Bob,
and that was incredibly disappointed when she heard Alexander was no longer
instructing,
but Walter insisted that she go anyway saying,
get in the car.
We're going.
Over the course of the five day painting class,
whatever misgivings and that fast had about Ross completely disappeared.
In fact,
taking that class,
she realized that was something very special about him looking back years later
and it said,
I was so mesmerized by Bob.
Somehow he lifted me out of that depression.
I just think that Bob knew how to woo people were willing people.
That was kind of Ross's calling cards and that was onto something and she saw in
Ross and opportunity to put it in a bottle and sell it.
She believed Ross was capable of making a fortune and she wanted in after the
class and Athens,
our husbands took Ross out to dinner and broken a business deal from that point
on and that's became Ross's manager thinking her entire life savings into the
partnership.
Ross and his wife ponied up a similar amounts of capital as a manager.
Then at focused on taking out ads in the local papers and setting up painting
seminars and various malls.
She even established a toll free telephone hotline,
1-800-BOB-ROSS.
That's for people to really connect and to experience the Alere of Bob Ross.
She needed to get him in front of as many people as possible.
They filmed to commercial.
Then it's possibly a pilot television show in order to sell it to PBS
executives.
Eventually,
all the hard work and hustle paid off and Ross landed his own show on the
network for joy of painting.
The first episode adds on January the 11th 1983 the joy of painting enjoyed an
11 year run on PBS from 1983 to 1994 filming for 103 episodes in total.
During the 30 minutes of our time for each show,
Ross,
it stood in a dark room with a blank canvas and it's painted and imaginary
landscape scene.
There were two cameras for the program she wants in real time,
a medium shot of Ross and his canvas and take close up shots of the canvas or
the Palette.
Ross faithfully instructed oil painting to viewers at home in the other premise
style,
the same technique he previously learned from Bill Alexander with there's a more
than smudges blockages and scrapes from his palace and Ros created masterpieces
to keep the lessons in expensive for people.
The tools and his color selection was limited though he surely had the technique
down.
Ross is real draw for audiences was his calming presence,
slower paced speech,
warm voice and words of encouragement sprinkled in while instructing.
In this way,
Ross is often compared to Fred Rogers,
the iconic children's show host of Mr. RogersRogers' neighborhood.
On the drive painting,
there was no pressure from Ross.
He believed everyone could paint almighty pictures and there are no mistakes or
only happy accidents.
The joy of painting proved to be an immediate success for the PDS network for
some of you is it was a reprieve from the harsh realities of life or the
doldrums of other television programs.
When asked about his concerning approach,
Ross said,
I got a letter from somebody here a while back and they said,
Bob,
everything in your world seems to be happy.
That's for sure.
That's why I paint.
It's because I can create the kind of world that I want and I can make.
This world is happy as I want.
It shoots.
If you want bad stuff,
watch the news.
The joy of painting was like a personal arts lesson described by his manager,
a nes as liquid tranquilizer.
Yes.
Amazingly,
only about 10% of viewers painted along with Ross,
the other 90% tune den.
Do you simply watch him?
Ros worked quickly to create his masterpieces,
swirling the pains around dabbing is here and there and grabbing for his two
inch brush every now and then and saying,
now let's get crazy.
He made the whole process of painting look completely effortless.
The truth is that Ross was meticulous and does manage it and that referred to
him as a tyrant.
Ross was not mean or nasty according to a nats,
but he was every bit as much a businessman as he wants a painter.
He wants it everything on the show to be perfect and done his way.
Before filming each episode,
Ross would lay awake at night planning and rehearsing exactly what he would say.
No one watching whatever.
No.
Ross always appeared to be calm and free form on camera is planning extended to
more than the words he said though for each episode of the dry of painting,
Ross didn't complete just one painting.
He always finished three ros pains had one while filming the one everyone saw
and other was done before in Santa,
just off camera for roster use as a reference and the final painting.
A more detailed work was completed after the show and was photographed for use
in Ross's instruction books.
Ross was never actually paid for appearing in any of the shows on PBS.
Instead he used it to remote is teaching business.
This worked spectacularly and interest in that expanded.
After just the first episode,
the Business Bob Rossing eventually grew to include paint supplies branded by
Bob Ross and the company and Ross wrecked in millions of dollars to further
bring his brand into the spotlight.
Ross occasionally appeared on talk shows and appeared in promotion or gigs.
Some of these includers MTV,
the Joan Rivers show Phil Donahue and as a guest to say Hank Snow Country Music
concert.
The final joy of painting show.
And on May the 17th 1994 after Ross was diagnosed with cancer,
Ross's son,
Steven,
who made regular appearances on the show,
apparently with his father on the set,
most of Ross,
his image was intentionally created except for his trademark Afro,
believe it on obs.
His hair wasn't even naturally curly.
It was straight before we officially had made us.
Ross ditched his shorts.
Military crew cuts for a longer style and palm as a way to save money.
Once his sperm was a hallmark of the Bob Ross brands,
he couldn't bring himself to change this,
even though he grew to dislike it.
Later after Ross got sick from lymphoma,
cancer ruins,
lost all his hair to chemotherapy treatments.
He wore a wig on.
It's showed to keep up as a parents Rossi's outfits where another Catholic
crafted elements off his look on the joy of painting Roswell or casual blue
jeans with a button up shirts.
The top buttons were left.
Undones reveal a bit of chest APP.
This timeless look was intended to appear currents.
When PBS add reruns of the show later on,
a private man Rawson does manager and that's told the back story of a life that
was light on biographical details.
The story emphasized modest beginnings,
a love of nature and animals,
and it's a philosophy that every person matters is caring personality extended
to his view as students and injured animals that he took in and cash for.
This narrative continues to be pushed today by the business.
Bob Ross Inc.
In 1994 raw Swiss dealt a devastating blow with his diagnosis of lymphoma.
A rat died of cancer.
Lymphoma is in a group of blood cancers.
It attacks the lymphatic system.
The lymph nodes and glands along with a network of vessels are an important part
of the body.
Circulatory functions that age in a person's immune system.
Many people with lymphoma never have or display symptoms and it isn't known how
much Ross suffered from his disease.
Ross kept his cancer diagnosis out of the public eye.
I need telling his closest friends and relatives.
He apparently painted right up things all the ends and died in 1995 at the age
of 52 that his grave at Woodlands Memorial Park in Florida.
Simple stone market reads Bob Ross television artist
Wilbur Ross was a prolific artist purportedly competing at 30,000 paintings
during his lifetime.
With so many Ross paintings out there in the world,
it would seem relatively easy to find one and bias in order to hang it above the
living room couch.
But this is not true anyone wanting to purchase one today,
it would be hard pressed to find an original.
The reason for this is because there are so many copycats and 40 live versions
that have flooded the marketplace.
Further,
virtually all of Ross's paintings made on the joy of painting had been donated
to PBS fundraisers to raise money for other public broadcasting programs.
Today,
the company,
Bob Ross Inc is still going strong and is still managed by Annette and Walter
Kowalski.
The company that sells a variety of paints,
brushes,
art kits,
easels,
canvases,
instructional DVDs and books on their website.
One kind of fines and order.
Bob Ross branded apparel,
including socks,
t shirts and baby bibs that are an array of accessories and wacky gifts
including coffee mugs,
glasses,
even a certified Bob Ross.
She had passed beyond owns the official merchandise.
So I'm going to find just about anything with the Bob Ross image.
A quick Google search even pretends of Brac handle named forceint Bob Ross.
Bob Ross is company.
It's still trains and certifies painting instructors who designed to work,
teach and promote themselves in the spirit of the artist.
Most recently Netflix is licensed shows adding Bob Ross's series.
Beauty is everywhere and just the joy of painting to its lineup in pop culture.
References to Bob Ross and his aphorisms everywhere has likened the
inspirational quotes live on through as an ad to memes.
Google celebrated Ross for what would have been his 70th birthday in 2012 with a
Google doodle and image of Ross painting the lesser g with a landscape in the
background.
He has been mentioned in many popular television shows such as family guy in the
boondocks.
Target stores even carry a Bob Ross board game called Bob Ross.
The Art of chill.
If all of this wasn't enough,
the Lego company has created a Bob Ross Lego figure completes with a paintbrush
and the Palette is icon.
Status today shows absolutely no signs of diminishing.
It seems Ross's legacy isn't ever going to die and just fans will continue to
honor and celebrate the man for years to come.
Ros One said,
didn't you know you had that much power?
You can move mountains,
you can do anything he showed us,
he could create a better place,
a world filled with happy little trees that was free of judgments where everyone
was an artist and every landscape was full of majestic wonder.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.